my guest this evening is a
self-described girl from the south side
she's also a former first lady a
best-selling author an amazing mother
and co-chair of when we all vote
a non-profit organization whose mission
is to increase
voter participation it is my great
pleasure to welcome
michelle obama so nice to see you again
it's great to see you too yeah don't say
this out loud
your hair looks cute you think it's cute
you like it
it's adorable thank you um it's
really that side foot you can do that
flip
there you go and i can soon what i want
to do is keep growing it
till it's like down to here and i want
to do that thing
that will be so much fun
you invite me back on when that happens
the thing that uh i see women do it in
reality shows all the time
they do this yes yes yeah you want to be
able to
do that you're getting close i'm getting
there uh
first of all you look fantastic as you
always do
um and uh i'm curious
first question i ask everybody these
days is how are you guys
holding up during the pandemic what's
what's the
obama routine what do you what is you as
a family because i know you're all holed
up together what do you do well it it
we've kind of had phases of covid there
was sort of the early stages where we
were all
excited to be together and we were being
all organized and
we would spend the days apart doing our
respective work the girls were
still in classes in the spring and so we
would
be working and then do a little exercise
then come together in the evenings
and we would have these activities we
would have cocktails and
then we would work puzzles and um
play games or talk the girls how to play
spades
oh really good we actually had some
organized things like we had an
art day an art exhibit day where we all
went off and did like
watercolor paintings and then showed it
now the conan this was in the early
stages yes
i'm familiar there was a there was a
period i know that we're going to say
there was a period of about
a month or two two maybe two and a half
months
of isn't this a rare opportunity for all
of us to enjoy each other's company as a
family
then that went away that went away and
it started i think
first our kids got a little sick of us
they they were
you know which was fine because we were
pretty much sick of them
and so the summer started happening and
then we could be outside a little bit
more
and we came to the vineyard where we
still are
and so there's more room to roam around
can you guess
and you know that was good because it
helped us break it up
and now the kids are back in zoom land
with classes
they're doing it remotely and they are
no longer thrilled about being with us
so no no no periodically for grunt
about you how about you uh and uh and
your husband
uh are there moments where you're
thinking we all
we tend to put figures like yourselves
and your husband up on a pedestal
and we forget that you too can have
moments of oh
it's that guy oh yeah oh yeah we've
talked about this i mean
you know it's you know the thing barack
was finishing his book
as it was just announced that he's uh
his books are going to be published
after the election so he's actually
spent most of this summer
locked away writing the book um so he's
had
limited time to get on my nerves but
then he sort of has gotten on my nerves
because
i haven't seen him enough you know he
can't he can't win
he can't win we all know that we know
that we can't win
i would think you would have some sense
of hey
excuse me guy i wrote my book
a long time ago huge hit uh
massive massive hit huge book tour
what's taking you so long do you ever
get to do that well his book is a little
bigger
a little more a little more historical
as he would say um but yeah
we we managed we're still together and
we're
and he's still alive
i think i would have read about it
somewhere if you two would split up
[Laughter]
you know i i was thinking about this
earlier today i had the
great pleasure spending some time with
your family with your mom
and your mom is such a social person
and i mean immediately you cannot
there's no such thing as talking to your
mom for 30 seconds
you start talking to your mom and the
next thing you know 20 minutes have gone
by and it's been delightful
i can't is your mom making it through
this period without all that social
connection
you know what she can be social when she
has to
but she is perfectly content on her own
i mean
the other day i call her and i'm like
how you doing she's like
i'm surprisingly fine maybe something's
wrong with me but i'm perfectly happy
not seeing people she kind of questioned
it
but she's a little routine going on um
and she's been good i think she's been
doing
some mild safe social distancing
with relatives you know outside things
like that
so it's kept her focused so she is
doing well thank you she is the
i think the least affected person i've
ever met
uh by this historic change that happened
in her life
when i would when i talked to her she
was
just had this attitude like well i'm
here now living in the white house
because
that's what's going on now i mean it was
really
incredible and and she had no there was
no sense that it changed her in any way
oh my god no no i mean and she just
played a pivotal role
in keeping us all grounded she is just
not impressed
with anything um not much of anything
the funniest thing is like when we were
in the white house and we'd do these
fabulous
you know international trips um and i
it was always like pulling teeth to get
her to go
you know i yeah we're going to china mom
and it's like
why would i want to go to china
the great wall history you know part of
the
you know you want to go to the vatican
see the pope it's like i think
didn't i meet the pope once before why
would i want to go back
to rome then i've seen it it's like
you might want to see it again so it was
always a level of just sort of
telling her this is kind of a big deal
you might want to be a part of it but
the one thing that would always get her
to say yes
was if i said the girls really want you
to come yeah that's
like oh oh okay well if the girls want
me to come then of course i'll come
for them right she's a trip she's
she's she's she still i always get the
sense i got the sense from your book and
i also got the sense from hanging around
a little bit with your brother
uh craig that that he's the favorite and
you think
what do you have to do what do you have
to do
you are known throughout the world
you are an iconic figure and she's still
like yeah pretty good
but uh but craig you got to get greg
the the the apple of her eye i mean he's
my favorite too
um he's he's actually a very sweet sweet
brother to have but no it's like she can
get him
he can get her to do anything even
moving into the white house i wrote
i was like i couldn't convince her to
come so i had to call craig and tell her
craig you got to make mom
come to the white house we need her
she's like oh of course
grace thinks it's a good idea
you know big brother mothers and their
sons you know she
it's me she loves me deeply that i know
but i think we've all concluded that
even it's his
own wife his own kids they know well if
you want grandma to do something like
craig calling
well you used your brother too you you i
i heard you say that you
you got your brother to sort of check
out
your uh you know boyfriend at the time
president obama uh and to see like what
how is he on the basketball court like
analyzed him for me
because you thought that that might tell
you something about his character
absolutely i mean we're we have always
been a big sports family
we you know my brother played tons of
sports played
you know i was all ivy and basketball
was a big part of our lives and my
father believed you could tell a lot
about a person by how they behaved on a
team
and i agreed with this so i thought you
know
i was dating him starting to get serious
i was introducing him to the family and
you know how people can
they show up well for your family but
right what do they do
when the stakes are really high what
happens on the court so
he took him out to play a pickup game
and
the the the reports were obviously good
because he stayed in my life
wasn't a bull hog um he said
he was good without being cocky
he wasn't afraid to pass the ball
um and he didn't do on the court what he
couldn't do like he didn't try to dunk
her
right that he clearly couldn't do so
all in all it was a good report and it
has wound up being
he's been pretty barack has been pretty
consistent you know
sure his character as we can see is our
nation's leader
yeah he's pretty honest shooter yeah
i uh first of all i'm i'm very glad he
had a good
game that day
[Laughter]
god knows how history would be different
second it occurs to me that
if uh if my
the women in my life had judged me on my
basketball prowess i would be a 57 year
old virgin right now
so
i really stayed away from the basketball
didn't
with great height does not come great
coordination i hate to tell you
well you have other things tell me what
they are at some point because i don't
know here
thank you thank you we'll leave it at
that smile
[Laughter]
wicked witch i mean yeah there we go
there we go thank you
basketball um who needs that you're
right i don't need that uh
i want to ask you briefly about uh the
you know there
was all this talk and excitement about
uh you and your husband having this
netflix deal and it occurred to me
i've seen your i've actually followed
your husband
at the white house correspondents dinner
and followed him as a comedian and he is
a tough act to follow he's very funny
is there any chance that uh that your
husband would do a netflix stand-up
special himself
any chance that's coming in the future
you know i yeah
i don't want to close any options
because who knows
um but i can safely say that stand-up
will not be
on the higher ground roster
that would certainly be a it would be a
strange turn no one would see that
coming because i know you have to
be like oh a comedy special from the
obamas huh yeah
just your husband just prowling the
stage with a mic
and with like a cat suit on or a little
pacing like chris rock or yeah you're
something red leather like eddie murphy
throwback stand
that's something to think about please
think about it
i'll call ted sarandos and see what he's
saying
please tell him please tell him i just
you know if
just i'm glad i just i'm picturing it in
my mind and i'm laughing
uh it's making me really laugh i do have
to
uh ask because it just happened that
very sadly we lost justice ruth bader
ginsburg
and i i know you and i have talked about
this before
my mother one of the early women to go
to
yale law school and you uh went to law
school
and and and worked very hard and i'm
wondering
what her legacy means to you um
where do i begin i mean you saw
through your experience with your mother
what it meant for women of her
generation
to go and obtain their law degree
at a time when women were not thought of
as being competent or smart enough to do
that
and the level of discrimination that
they faced
in law school and in their firms
afterwards
i just think about that and think about
the determination
and the sheer intelligence it took for
people
like justice ginsburg and your mother
and so many other women
well not many of them because there were
very few of them
in that generation um who were at the
front lines of
of of opening up opportunities for all
of us
and her entire legal career her time
on the supreme court um really
pushed open a new set of possibilities
for women all over the country and all
over the world
and to lose that kind of icon in this
time
that we're in because we are facing some
difficult times
it's heartbreaking um but it
it should also be eye-opening um we
talk about in every election we talk
about
why it's important to vote and the
impact that who's in the oval office
makes to the supreme court in those
appointments
right sometimes that doesn't feel real
to people it's not motivating enough
because they're like well
what does this mean the supreme court a
lot of people don't understand but now
that we've lost
this icon and the balance of power on
the supreme court
lays in in the hands of
of of this sitting president and will
impact the lives of young people for
generations to come
it is all too real what having someone
like her
on the court has meant um but it makes
it plain
that we cannot take this election for
granted um
not now not ever um so
she was an icon a great role model to me
and a dear friend to me and to barack
and she will be sorely missed let's talk
about something
that is of crucial importance and that
is uh the deadline to vote
is around the corner and i know this is
a major cause of yours
and i think it's something that
everybody's concerned about
right now uh which is
the number of people that will decide
this election the number of people that
decided the last election
was so razor thin that everyone needs to
understand
how important their vote is it's crucial
oh and
you know it amazes me to hear people say
well i didn't vote because i didn't
think it mattered
and um as you mentioned this last
election
uh in in some of the swing states the
margin of difference
was five votes per precinct and that
wasn't
just unique to this past election i mean
i have been
campaigning in midterm elections and
in the last several elections and i've
looked at the statistics and
every time you look at the margin of
victory because
we have such a low voting percentage in
this country
that for every election at every level
we're talking about 1 2 5 10
50 votes that determine who your mayor
is who your governor is who
your you know council member is um
so every vote absolutely matters and
people just take this for granted
and then when it doesn't turn out the
way they had hoped
uh they're shocked and upset
um but this is a democracy and
yes sometimes it's frustrating and
sometimes it can be alienating i
i get that but i've also traveled the
world
and i've seen other forms of government
and i wouldn't trade our democracy for
anything in the world but in order for
it to work
we need active engaged and informed
citizens who are ready to do the one
pretty simple thing which is vote and
you can
mail it in you can stay in line if you
want
you can vote early you can do it always
yes
we could have more ways to vote it could
be easier
and we hopefully with the right
leadership we'll get
um voting requirements that will be
easier
uh but right now it's pretty easy
yeah it takes some planning um
and and and people can get the
information they need
but we just can't afford for people to
take the attitude that voting doesn't
count
uh it it absolutely does well uh
you know that's one of the this cause
that you've been working on
uh so hard that your co-chair is when we
all vote
and you have a lot of people working
across the country very hard to educate
people in each state
about what they need to do to register
how they need to vote
it's really important and i thought it
might be a nice
treat for some of these hard-working
young people i thought it might be fun
if we surprised a couple of them
with a little zoom bomb and it might
lift their spirits
right now because we know they're
working so hard would you like to do
that that sounds like a great idea
like hopefully we after us we just have
like so many people
who don't stay silent when they're like
in the face of injustice
um when there is there are people in
power
who are doing rock everybody excuse me
i just wanted to say hello uh conan
o'brien here
and i just want i know the hard work
that you're doing i mean i i'm really
impressed with when we all vote
i i wanted to pop in and just very
quickly
thank you all for all the work you're
doing and we're gonna show this on my
late night program tonight
i wish you'd cleaned up some of you
would
have killed you to clean up i hope this
is okay i wanted to say
hello and if you're cool with it is it
okay i have a friend who just wanted to
say a quick hi is that all right
let me just hold on a sec here we go
oh my goodness what are you guys
talking about changing the world
this is obama i was telling them i wish
some of them had cleaned their rooms
your room is perfectly clean i'm looking
at
you you guys look like you're doing good
i know that this group is working really
hard on uh
on on getting the vote out and doing so
much
there's one woman here who uh is about
to get out of her car and do stairs
uh our team's a little bit out of shape
from coven
being quarantined all this time so we
have a lot of stairs to make up
oh my god conan you need to do that what
are you talking about
i mean what makes you think i'm not in
perfect physical condition this is obama
your hair is a little too perfect it's
not look
how's that don't you like onan's hair
you guys
i mean love conan's hair thank you very
much i love that during this
incredibly tense time in our in historic
time in our nation
we have the former first lady uh talking
to you guys who are out getting working
so hard to get the vote out
and the conversation has gone to my hair
absolutely ridiculous and absurd
mrs obama i know she feels the same way
i do that we're just really grateful to
you guys for doing so much hard work
very impressive that you guys are
managing to stay
so focused on getting people registered
and to get them informed
and you're you know doing your classes
online and
staying involved in your teams and
running stairs and
you know i mean it's just amazing but
it's
it's work that is so needed um it is so
important for you guys to get your
generation and your peers and your
family members focused on this election
the work that you're doing couldn't be
more important and i am
so proud of you and it's like when i see
your faces that makes me want to work
harder because i think you all deserve
leadership that reflects who you all are
and you guys are good and smart and kind
and open
and caring and you deserve leadership
that reflects that
so keep working hard please and we love
you so much
conan aren't these that you mean ah see
if you like conan speechless
yeah i i just i'm very impressed with
these kids again
i think some of the rooms could be
cleaner but i'm gonna shut up about it
well thank you all very very much and i
i leave the final sign off to mrs obama
oh
you guys keep up great work um
study hard stay safe wear your masks i'm
gonna be a mother eat your vegetables
and give your families my love and your
classmates tell them to vote vote vote
vote vote
vote okay let's have a cheer for mrs
[Applause]
obama
there's no better segue than we have 40
days until
the election so make sure you head over
to when
we all vote dot org this is crucial
get registered to vote make your plan to
vote early it's so important that we all
make our voices heard
uh again always an honor just a
incredible honor to speak with you uh
thank you for taking the time
and um you know uh and and please
let me know anything we can do to help
uh
we'll we're we're we're down to do it i
can always count on you
well no that's not true
you can yes you can
most people can't but you can thank you
very much
thank you